some Republicans are actually speaking
up and I've sort of been laying it out
for you but here's Kevin McCarthy on
what he would do right now
voters have voted to change the
Republicans would be in power in 15 days
so why wouldn't we simply do a
continuing resolution fund the
government into the next year and then
we'd have an opportunity to actually cut
spending they are going to increase
they're going to increase by more than
100 billion dollars after all the
increases they've done for so now the
Baseline when we take over is going to
be a hundred billion dollars more adding
more to inflation these two senators
Leahy and Shelby won't have to face the
voters because they're leaving they
won't even tell us what the numbers are
and they're going to show a bill that
are thousands of pages that nobody can
read and then what the Democrats did was
to pass the continuing resolution right
up to Christmas and pressure us to pass
this bill which is wrong we should hold
on and let Republicans help us secure
the Border in funding this government
the Republicans are about to have some
power as he said in 15 days the
Republicans are about to be able to do
some things and all of these sellouts
Mitt Romney and all the rest of them
they are going to sign this thing that
the thing's going to pass like it's just
it is what it is it's entropy the
government constantly works with entropy
it just moves and moves and moves and
moves and a bunch of us try to fight it
and you can get little wins here and
there but the thing just moves right but
McCarthy's absolutely right get us to
the end of the year we'll take over and
then
we could do this
we could rip the freaking thing up and
we could figure out other ways to fund
things instead of just endlessly
spending and funding the war and funding
these agencies that have worked against
us the American people and everything
else